in the pre-dawn hours from high in the
Wasatch Mountains Salt Lake City looks
like dancing fireflies you're climbing
to an elevation of 11,000 feet just to
make a morning meeting
forecast is for increasing clouds 1 2 3
today 4 to 5 tonight this room is packed
with experience even with 7 years on the
job you're still a rookie 26 years is a
long time to be doing anything
especially a job that's can be as
demanding as this one it's 17 degrees
the wind scrapes across your face and
you take it all in stride action is what
you do interested gets the adrenaline
going
it makes me want to get outta bed the
morning come to work Dean Carter now and
his colleagues speed to keep people safe
there the ski patrol at Snowbird ski
resort their work space stretches 2,500
acres skiing to work skiing home there's
nothing I'd rather do it is an office
that's constantly demanding sunup
sundown every day I think you want to do
okay Kelly
I got a backboard phone five Holly do
you want to go and look at the no guns
on Wilbur Ridge
for a handful of ski patrollers training
goes beyond the emergency medical
procedures it takes additional
specialized instruction to handle
ammunition and operate military
artillery to trigger avalanches to
literally blow them off the mountain
when an avalanche forecast calls for
action ski areas are closed while the
guns fire they're trying to control
nature before it can harm unsuspecting
skiers at least once a week
snowbirds ski patrol practices what it
calls hasty rescues this is the time and
practice has to be perfect
buried alive in snow help has got to
come within minutes late 1980s control
route I was swept away and buried by an
avalanche my head was 6 feet down and
within eight minutes they had located me
and I was blue and unbreathing things
can quickly turn serious when you need
help on the mountain but you improve
your chances by wearing an avalanche
homing device or by having a computer
chip sown in your clothes both send out
signals for help a lot of times the
public doesn't see exactly what we do
because we do it in closed areas behind
lines what the public does see are men
and women who work on the mountain for
the love of
I wake up everyday in a beautiful place
in a natural environment every snowflake
that falls makes the whole world
different in you doing a job they
wouldn't trade with an incomparable view